[Music]
he
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud L proud proud and do not
give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them
oh row rage is
[Music]
building it's
coming and it's going to [__] vote
that's right but they're going to double
down on it um it's very clear by the the
rhetoric of Nikki Haley and the support
that Nikki Haley has for criminalizing
Women's
Healthcare in this
country figured this was going to be a
good topic uh to talk about today as we
go into the holidays because I know that
you're going to gather up with your
family your
friends the women that you love that's
right the women that you
love and I'm sure this is going to be a
topic for
conversation over the holidays as you
share food and gifts laughter and
memories with the women in your life
life the little
girls who will have to live under these
fascist regimes in these
states where their grandmothers and
their mothers had more rights than they
did in a progressive Nation are you
[__] kidding
me now Nikki Haley's doubling
down on the overturning of roie Wade of
course of course Grandpa Hitler takes
credit for over rning roie Wade which
makes it very simple and very easy
because we all we all know who the
nominee is going to
be we all
know who the nominees is going to be we
have several pieces of business today
that I want to get to
first before we dive into the Tony
Michaels
rant and I give you a
little boxing tips on how to spar with
your relatives and how to frame it for
people who were like-minded because this
is very important right it's very
important to help frame it for people
who are
like-minded so we'll get to that I
promise and I'll show you clips of Nikki
Haley hating on women and wanting to
criminalize Women's Health
Care and ban their privacy and not
offices that's right they want to
criminalize being pregnant and they want
to ban your privacy they don't want you
they want big government in your
doctor's office they want it in your
bedroom and in your vagina that is where
they want big government they they they
it do want to have nothing to do with
penis
unless of course these weirdos just may
or may not think that a woman has a
penis it's weird stuff I know
but they're [__] weirdos they're
[__]
weirdos fascists are [__] weird and
they have a weird world
view and it shows but first I want to
get to some business we have a birthday
in the chat Deborah Ellis's birthday is
today happy birthday Deborah happy
birthday to you happy birthday to you
happy birthday Deborah everyone wish
Deborah a happy birthday if anyone else
has got a birthday in the chat happy
birthday to you too as
well I also want to take because people
on Tuesday usually Texas Paul's here
he's going to be taking a break from the
show he's taking hi as he is going to be
working on a project a big project so he
needs more time so we won't have Texas
Paul on Tuesdays as much anymore he may
come visit now and then but for a while
he's going to take off to work on a big
project that he's working on
for this next
election so we'll hand that so it's just
it's just my pretty little face today of
course maybe at the end of the day the
guy with the last name Sanchez may join
us he's supposed to be doing a show this
afternoon right after this show what was
that live with Gabe Sanchez on YouTube
and twitch I think he's been I think
he's gonna be broadcasting to Instagram
too that's something new we're
broadcasting to Instagram if anyone
gives a [__]
I don't maybe a few people are watching
over there on
Instagram it doesn't stay there I don't
know maybe maybe some audience members
know more about in I'm sure there's
plenty of audience members that know
more way more about Instagram than I do
because I don't know [__] [__] about
Instagram I know how a [__] post over
there you know what I mean like I can
post a meme or a video but that's about
as far as my knowledge
goes I don't know about lives or any of
that [__] I don't know I I really I'm
really not very good at descriptions and
linking the descriptions and all that
[__] I don't know I just don't know
Instagram very [__] well I know it as
about as well as Facebook and that ain't
diddly [__] squat
so maybe I'll have to get schooled up
and learned on
Instagram oh boy you know I really
[__] hate social media platforms I'm
gonna be quite honest I don't know if
you guys noticed that I just there's so
many of them and like the expectation
for um someone like me to be on all the
platforms and post all my [__]
everywhere on the platforms it's a
little overwhelming so I want to thank
the people now that we're getting to the
holiday season who are behind the scenes
that help out the show that are part of
the [__] them fam um and and they do a
lot of that for us of course you guys
know we have the sidekick small rat uh
we have the
clipmaster skip the meme General Derek
the queen of the queen of PR Ty Ros uh
we have our local librarian Mighty
Library the Mighty the mighty librarian
and of course we have all of our Mod
Squad here in the chat so I just I just
want to thank those people because they
really do help um me with the social
stuff cuz I sucks at it that's right I'm
I'm horrible at it I'm not very good
like sometimes I tweet in the morning
before I really woke up before I finish
my coffee and finish my walk and I'm
tweeting and then I go back and read it
later I'm like godamn that sounds dumb
as [__] but I don't delete it I don't
give a [__] and some people will correct
me they're like ah you got it wrong I'm
like ah I spell weirds okay I'm not the
best spellers in the world I just ain't
so you know I gotta admit I just I don't
I'm not I'm not much on the Social Media
stuff but you got to do it these days
because it's part of
engaging like there's in there's in
where real life right there's in real
life and then there's
[__] Digital Life right and all of it
all of it activating and engaging in it
is important it really is I mean it it
truly is that's that's what we're
actually looking for um is more
engagement in your democracy
and I think U there's going to be two
ISS I was on Hal spark show yesterday
and he asked me what the two issues that
I think should get more attention and
I'm like there's well there's only two
[__] issues right
now that are going to make sure we
secure our democracy only two only [__]
only two okay there's only two issues
you need to stay concentrated
on that is it that Donald Trump and the
Maga cult want him to be a dictator
and that they want to criminalize
women's
healthare those two things that's it
period if you want to win this
election for democracy you know what I
mean like not not just at the top of the
ticket I'm very confident that Joe Biden
is gonna absolutely [__] trounce
Grandpa Hitler here it's it's gonna be
[__] crazy the amount of votes that
are piled on top of that stupid
[__] who is saying he wants to
be the next Hitler it's really stupid
[__] like the last thing in the world
that any presidential candidate in
America wants to say is that they want
to be a dictator even if they're just
joking that is a thing you do not want
to
say I talked about it yesterday it goes
against the absolute entire fabric that
is America's so American
society
okay all right got it all right we can
move on from
that but those are the two big
issues and those are the two issues that
you need to be gabbing about everywhere
all the time forget [__] Gaza forget
Israel forget [__]
Palestine forget about Vol kanano forget
about the cat videos I'm telling you if
you want to win the election you just
pound this drum and make everything and
anything about those two issues that's
it now I'm I'm just I'm just advocating
to win the election for democracy right
that's it that's all I'm doing and I
want to politicize these two issues to
the fullest extent that can make us win
not just the presidency but the Senate
the house governorships all the way down
the [__] ballot all the way down to
the goddamn dog catcher that's right if
you're a dog catcher you you better you
better be for women's rights to Health
Care all right and you better say that
[__] out loud or you're not going to get
voted in as dog catcher godamn
it that's the attitude that we need to
have in this country oh you want a
dictator no dog catcher for you got it
pretty simple pretty
easy every single issue can be these two
issues every single one of them because
really truly they're kind of one and the
same if you think about it
I mean if you really get down to Bare
Bones because look fascists attack the
vulnerable first right the easiest
attacks they can make they make those
attacks and it was very easy to convince
[__] [__] eaters that women shouldn't
have the right to health care it was
really easy they've been priming this
pump for [__] 45 50 years folks
4550 years they have been setting this
narrative in place ever all the way back
to Jerry fwell not the one who [__]
the po boy or his wife [__] the pool
boy and he watched the other one his dad
the other cuck the other white Christian
Nationalist and that's how these two
things are
related I want to be a dictator
and we want to take away women's rights
to health care we want to criminalize
being pregnant they're criminalizing
pregnancy in States they're going to
try that's how you should say
it stop saying the a word stop saying SM
Moran stop saying it stop it just like
don't say Universal do not say those
[__] words stop using those words you
do not have to have a discussion about
Women's Healthcare and use the word
abortion you do
not you don't don't do
it don't do
it that's the [__] fight they want
you to have is what is it what is it is
it killing babies is it not killing
babies that's the [__] fight they
want you to have that is not the debate
that we're having here that's not the
debate what is or what isn't
ation the debate is is they want to
criminalize
pregnancy they want to criminalize
Women's Health Care the Republican Nazis
all over the [__] country want to ban
women's privacy
okay everyone knows what the [__] you're
talking about when you say that
[__] like like when I say like when I
say people don't want to go broke
because of a medical bill people know
what the [__] I'm
saying stop using the words that they
use to get you in a debate that is not
the actual
debate and I'm just trying to do this
before the holidays because I feel that
it's really important and it's not just
important to debate people who are
[__] [__]
eaters and they don't have enough brain
cells to rub together to see what's
coming with Grandpa Hitler wanting to be
Donnie dict taster and take away all
women's rights All
lgbtqq communi rights all parental
rights they want to take them all away
from
you all of them and they just they
always start at
women because these old wrinkly white
ball sacks believe that everyone wants
the woman to be submissive she should be
in the in the kitchen and Barefoot
having babies like that's their [__]
their delusion the alternate reality
that they [__] live
in but it's the truth that they believe
that
[__] so we have to take advantage of
this now you can't just debate those
[__] eaters right it is so important
that you go into the holidays when
you're going to be mixing with your
friends your family the women that you
love the men that you love that have
women that they love ain't it kind of
funny ain't it kind of funny how every
person in this country is affected by
Women's Health Care every [__]
even us men that's right I have a
daughter I have a mother I have a wife I
have friends that are women huh
yes my my life is affected because the
ones I love are affected okay it's a
thing and I want
them to have the same Liberties that is
granted to me because I have a set of
nuts that's what I want I want them not
to have their health care criminalized I
want them not to have their [__]
privacy
banned and it's important when we when
we talk to our friends and our family
about politics especially the ones
who agree with us that we make sure that
their narrative is on track that's where
I'm really going with this because
you're never ever ever going to convince
one of these Nazis that they shouldn't
take away rights from women you're not
going to do it like you can sit there
and talk to them and back and forth and
back and forth and back and forth but
they're Nazis okay they're [__]
Nazis when when when Nikki Haley is
sitting there saying I agree with Texas
and and Ken Paxton that woman should
have died [__]
her because she couldn't control the
condition of her
pregnancy she had no she had she had no
control over the condition of her
pregnancy she wanted to be pregnant
Nikki you [__] slug she wanted to
have that baby she actually wants to
have a procedure so she can continue
having [__] babies you know creating
life so it's very
important when you're talking to
likeminded people that they get the
messaging
right A lot of people don't pay
attention to politics every day they're
they're kind of on our side right
they're like yeah we need to save
democracy [__] Trump [__] this [__]
where they're [__] taking away
women's rights and criminalizing their
Healthcare and banning their privacy
like yeah we're not all we're not on
board with that we see that in all these
votes in Kansas Kentucky uh uh Montana
Michigan Ohio
Virginia we see it all around the
country okay this is not a popular
[__] view where they want to
criminalize Women's Health Care and they
and they want to ban women's [__]
privacy it's not popular at all not even
a little bit I mean so much so that a
House member in Missouri a state house
rep in Missouri files a bill to make it
a class a felony for a women to see have
a procedure to save her
life now class a felony could be 30 up
to 30 years even can even can have
consideration of the death penalty in
Missouri so the solution for a woman
having a [__] medical procedure to
save her life in Missouri just might get
her
dead either way they're
[__] women women in this
country they actually are receiving this
healthc care and I don't know if you
[__] wrinkly old white ball sacks are
aware of that or not but they actually
know their
bodies they've educated themselves this
is 2023 you [__]
bonehead they've heard a little bit
about how how pregnancy works and when
you have complications what it means to
them and their body and their
life but there are folks out there that
are on our
side that don't necessarily vote the way
we vote don't aren't necessarily excited
about
politics but this issue is an issue that
you can talk to them
about it's an important [__]
issue very important to
everyone it doesn't matter if it's just
a childbearing age woman I mean we have
we have daughters we have mothers we
have sisters we have wives we have
friends all people we love in our lives
and they're all affected by these
[__] decisions that these Nazis are
making to criminalize their
pregnancies and strip away and ban their
privacy I know I keep repeating myself
that's what you should
do make sure you when you're having
these conversations with your family and
friends over the
holidays make
sure make sure you explain why it's not
about abortion that's why you do not
have that's why you do not have to use
that word okay you do not have to use
that
word it's very important
that you explain to them the narrative
and why the narrative is important and
use the words over and over and over and
over and over and over again and I know
sometimes it feels like I'm beating a
drum with the same words continually
that's the
point folks how do you think MAA has con
been convinced that they need a
dictator do you think they just woke up
yesterday and were like yeah you know
what Donnie dict taster
we're going to make him Grandpa Hitler
that sounds great
no that is not what
happened the same stupid lies the same
stupid messaging it's sticky but it's
stupid has been pounded into their
[__] brains where they barely have
enough brain cells to rub together to be
functional over and over and over and
over and over again
again it is how it
works that's why I sit here every single
weekday Monday through Friday two full
[__] hours and say the same [__] over
and
over just in a little different way with
a little different video with a little
different spin maybe we're talking about
butt plugs maybe we're talking about
something
else it's the
point we have to get narrative straight
we cannot we
cannot we cannot sit back and let them
control the narrative and frankly The
Narrative is very
easy if liberals and Democrats and the
left and moderates and independents who
really care about women in this country
and really care about whether whether
Nazis are going to criminalize their
health care and ban their
privacy then we need to care and we need
to repeat it over and over and over
again the correct way don't type out the
word abortion don't do
that don't say the word
abortion in front of
people criminalizing women's healthare
and banning their
privacy what does that mean explain it
to
him now tomorrow we'll go over the dict
taster thing because those are the two
issues those are the two [__] issues
and when how asked me that yesterday
he's like what's the two issues what's
the two issues going in the next year I
was like you know what I got two shows
two shows before the Christmas break
because we're gonna take a Christmas
break tomorrow will be our last show
until next
Wednesday so so tomorrow will be our
last show until next Wednesday and then
we'll come back on Wednesday and we'll
do Wednesday Thursday Friday we'll take
off that next Monday Tuesday for New
Year's and we'll come back Wednesday
Thursday Friday and then we're just
gonna go balls deep into row rage oh
baby we're going to piss them off it's
gonna happen they're gonna be really
[__] upset with
us they're gonna be really [__] upset
with us I'm talking about the [__]
eaters because I'm telling you if you're
if you're watching the the mainstream
media number one turn that [__] [__]
off listen anyone feeding you poles and
saying that Donald Trump is winning with
people 30 and under is [__] brain
dead any news agency that looks at that
poll and goes what the [__] is this poll
talking
about listen if they show you that poll
turn them the [__] off turn it off turn
it
off they're horrible at narrative they
are horrible at messaging they are
trying to scare you into believing
nonsense it's stupid ass [__] it's dumb
you do not have to use lies to [__]
get people engaged and activated in
their democracy I'm so sick of that [__]
I don't care who it's from I don't give
a [__] I don't even care if they're
friends of mine I don't give a
[__] if you're using lies to try to
activate people you are doing it wrong
there is a strong American optimism
there is a strong optimism for democracy
in this country I see it every
[__] day in this goddamn chat
and ain't it ain't just the thousands of
people that watch this [__]
show I'm telling you this is the fabric
of our Democratic constitutional
republic it is the Deep fabric it is
what holds us all together even if we
can't [__] stand each other it is
what holds us together and for them to
get on the news and lie to us to try to
scare us to do something [__] that [__]
[__] them [__] them the media does not
control the narrative anymore that's why
they [__] that's why they [__]
hate people like me that's why the MSNBC
producers come and watch me they have to
watch this [__] if they don't watch this
[__] they're behind
Jesus Christ they're just now catching
up oh [__] they're talking about oh
Donald Trump's saying stuff from mind C
and blood po he's been saying this [__]
for months months he's been using the
frea phrase blood poisoning when he's
talking about
immigrants months he's been saying this
[__] in interviews with a bunch of
[__] white white Christian
nationalist he just now is getting in
front of a microphone and reading it off
the teleprompter and then [__]
posting it on true
social so the media not being able to
pick up on the Nazi [__] that's been
going on for the last [__] six years
with the MAA cult [__] you [__]
you just coming around to this
[__] I'm telling you if you want to stay
ahead of what the hell is going to
happen this is the place to do it I know
I'm kind of Pat myself on the back
but the reason why it is is because I'm
not scared to tell you I'm not scared
I'm not I don't give a [__] if someone's
not going to sponsor me I don't care if
[__] YouTube bans me I don't give a
[__] if they won't monetize me I don't
care if Facebook [__] bans me I don't
give a [__] the message is way more
important than any kind of monetization
that I could get the message is way more
important than any [__] any [__]
way that that I could broadcast [__]
them [__] them [__] them [__] them our
democracy is way more important than my
YouTube channel folks way [__] more
important and I am proud that I am that
this microphone and this show and I
empowered by you to [__] fight
fascism in this
country and I'm telling you the best way
to fight fascism is a
message and a
narrative and we have an opportunity
over the holidays when you go and you
sit in front of people who don't
normally pay attention to politics and
you have five maybe 10 minutes maybe you
got an hour but five or 10 minutes to
talk about these two
topics and pound it in their brains
because what they'll do is they'll go
back to work and they'll talk to Folks
at work and those folks will go talk to
the people at the PTA and they'll go
talk to [__] people at the church
they'll go talk to people at their Town
Council meetings I'm telling you it will
[__]
snowball next year is going to be a big
year it's going to be a big year not
just for the country not just for the
election but for this audience there's
going to be more and more people
Gathering up around this
show it's gonna
happen I I I know I know a lot of haters
out there like yeah Tony you only get
three people that view you on Twitter
okay all
right there's thousands of you that view
this show every single day whether you
listen on iTunes are you listening on
Spotify you're watching on YouTube
You're viewing it on Twitch you're
seeing it on Facebook or now
Instagram thousands and it's going to
build and the only reason why is because
I'm not scared to tell you the [__]
truth and the truth of the matter is is
that they're coming for for you they're
coming for your way of
life everything that you hold dear your
family your friends your
job your public schools your community
they're coming for
it they're coming for
it and they're not going to stop either
they're not going
to even even if we win this election big
time and we beat back fascism they're
not going to stop it's going to keep
going they're salivating for a dictator
Jesus Christ the guy that wants to be
the dictator is saying it out loud and
they're yelling and screaming that they
want him to be a
dictator this is not going anywhere
anytime soon this is a disease
folks this disease is run rampant in our
country and Donald Trump is just a
symptom
overturning roie Wade is just a
symptom of
fascism it won't stop there trying
trying to trying to take away parents'
rights from trans kids it won't stop
there trying trying to demonize and
ostracize lgbtq community and cast them
out of our
communities and and and in American life
it won't stop
there it's not going to stop there
trying to force us to be Christians it
won't stop
there that's not how fascism
Works it'll keep going if we don't stand
in its
way and the one cryptonite that fascism
has is
democracy they [__] hate it that's
why fascists [__] hate democracy they
[__] hate
it because it keep keeps them out of
power pure plain
simple know it know the narrative know
the language spread it around this
Christmas holiday give it as the best
Christmas gift that you can give because
it will be the best Christmas gift you
can give and also don't forget to tell
them about this [__] show Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific for two full hours and every
single weekday don't go anywhere we'll
be right back right after
this what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetorical question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast letters from the trucker
Convoy there's Tammy by the time we
reached DC weight was 50 strong in
number some patriots ran out of gas
along the way we got plenty of slim gems
and
skull near run out Natty light hope it
don't rain tomorrow so we can Circle the
city again here's Bob dear Bob I'm
fixing to send you some more of them
Doritos you like the red bag not the
live Ling blue one and your reps since I
discovered a rash on my neck and no it
ain't no hickey and I a even seen my
cousin bro in
ages stay strong wipe your ass at least
once a day yours
tamy [__] them [__] [__] them [__] [__]
them [__] we're back to the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast welcome back to the
show we're live Facebook YouTube twitch
and
Instagram on all the
platforms that's right Tony is
[Music]
Unchained I was banned from Facebook for
30 days and they Banned Me from YouTube
for seven days um
so you get to come listen uh right now
to a guy who um they they obviously
don't want me to say certain [__] but
we're going to say it
anyways and the reason why is because it
needs to be
said we can't walk away from this
stuff and we have to get the messaging
correct no matter no matter no matter
how much anyone pushes back on
us okay and I and I know it first it may
seem you know because a lot of people
push back on on me about um the 14th
Amendment stuff where they're trying to
14th
Trump and I think I turn a lot of people
that it's
anti-democratic that it's not the way
that we should
win how we win is going to matter folks
it's going to
matter it's going to
matter it's going to matter
but how big we win is going to matter as
well now a lot of people don't like my
stance
on Liz Cheney Paul Ryan Adam kin singer
Chris Christie don't give a [__] that's
the narrative we have to have folks I
know I know a lot of of people like but
Tony they're in our Coalition no they're
not they're in a completely different
Coalition they're trying to use our
Coalition as their means to their end we
should not do that
no it's not what we should do they did
this to
themselves the Republican party has
created a situation where someone like
Nikki
Haley has to go out in front of a town
hall and advocate for a National
Abortion ban now I don't know if you
know this but the Republican party just
a few years ago when they were
overturning roie way were like this is
about States rats this is about States
rats and now they're advocating Nikki
Haley is
advocating for a National Abortion
ban
now there's a lot of different reasons
why Nikki Haley is doing
this there's a lot of reasons
okay one of them is
because she wants to save the Republican
Party the same thing that Liz Cheney
wants to do the same thing that Adam
keninger wants to do the same thing that
Chris Christie wants to
do she believes that she can be the
nominee it's really [__]
dumb it's really [__] dumb so much so
that she is
partnering with with Chris Christie and
Donald Trump in her campaign to try to
position herself to win in north north
and excuse me New Hampshire and South
Carolina that's what she's trying to
do now unbeknownst to her because she's
not very politically
Savvy by partnering ing her messaging
with Chris Christie and partnering her
messaging against Ronda santz with
Donald Trump she's
losing is what she's doing Republicans
are not listen Republicans all across
the country are trying to
criminalize pregnancy they're trying to
ban women's privacy you think what
they're going to do is nominate a
woman
that's a good one that's almost as good
as Donald Trump was hungry and then he
wasn't eating that's good that's [__]
good that's a good lie I'm not I'm not
I'm not I'm gonna tell you the truth
that's a good [__] lie that's
hilarious Nikki Haley a woman is gonna
be the nominee of the Republican party
you [__] kidding
me that's good that's man that's that's
rich I I I'll give you the politics of
it if you want to hear it Chris Christie
is trying to um Court Niki Haley's
supporters in New Hampshire and South
Carolina by by making sure that no one
is attacking her as a woman okay that's
what he's doing I explained this at the
debate when he defended her against V
radad dingdong you remember this when V
radad dingdong was my name correctly
was really going after Nikki
Haley and Chris chriss's like you should
really leave her alone she's just a
woman you should leave her
alone and you
should treat women the way that women
should be treated you know have them
Barefoot in the kitchen pregnant I mean
criminalize it if it's a certain type of
pregnancy but that's how you should do
it you shouldn't be treating her that
way Chris Christie is trying to court
Nikki Haley's voters in New Hampshire in
South Carolina because Chris Christie is
correct politically he's correct he's
going to win over a lot of Nikki Haley's
voters that want to vote for Nikki Haley
but she's a woman so they'll vote for
the guy who protects the
woman especially the woman who advocates
for a National Abortion
ban okay that's that's the primary
politics of
it and Nikki Haley is
stupidly using spend a ton of [__]
rich people's money to attack Ronda
santz which is only helping Donald
Trump Donald Trump knows this the Trump
campaign knows this they want Nikki
Haley in this race because they want her
to attack Ronda STIs with the big money
donors in the Republican party because
he can't get the big money donors
because he's talking about being a dict
taster he can't get the big money donors
he's like yeah I want to be grand Paul
Hitler ha all that Nazi stuff and
more and they're like whoa whoa whoa
whoa hey easy on the whole MC thing
there Captain
victim so they're giving their money to
Nikki Haley which she's
using against Ronda santis which is what
Trump and the Trump campaign wants
literally if the big money donors were
giving that money to Trump trump will be
using it the same way Nikki Haley
is do you see how the Republican party
is [__] dead do you see it do you
[__] see it
yet that's why I'm telling you do not
[__] do not act like Liz Cheney Paul
Ryan Adam kin Chris Chrissy are our
friends [__]
them listen when you are on the outs
with the Nazis you don't get back in
ends okay you don't get back ends with
the Nazis that is not how it
works that is not how fascism Works once
you're on the outs you're on the
outs there's no going back there's no
undoing the dissidents that Chris
Christie that Liz Cheney Adam kinzinger
Mitt Romney Ken Buck there's no undoing
their
dissidence and let me tell you something
if these fascists win they're really
[__] so why do you think they're
fighting so
hard they're not fighting for our
interest our interest is democracy we
want to see our our [__] American
experiment
continue that's what we
want yeah it's not perfect democracies
aren't it's it's
difficult democracy is
difficult it's hard to compromise when
so many people have so many different
ideas I mean yeah sometimes there's a
consensus
around a good idea but very rarely do we
have a a national consensus in the 80s
or
90s it's just not something that happens
democracy is [__] hard liberalism is
hard it's why liberalism is actually
strength not
weakness
so anyone that tells you liberalism is
is is
snowflakerose a place for a federal law
oh oh and you see how she uses the
word
Moran again these they're trying to get
you in a discussion about that and a
debate about
that right that's that's their [__]
angle their stupid [__]
angle because they don't make the
consideration that those procedures are
a broad spectrum of healthare that women
receive in this
country they you're never going to
convince them of the [__] truth about
that you
won't even if they actually believe it
they won't [__] admit
it but just just a few years ago all
these Republicans are talking about
states rights right ah states rights
it's about the states right what the
states decide
side here's Nikki
Haley because she knows she has to say
it to even have a [__] shot to
win because she knows she's already
[__] giving away part of her
coalition to Chris Christie she knows
that and you can go look at the polls
and throw the polls at me I don't give a
[__] what the polls say I don't give a
[__] I don't give a
[__] I go off I go off I go off the
polls that matter those are [__]
elections those are the [__] polls
that matter and I'm telling you right
now Chris Christie is courting the New
Hampshire vote in the South Carolina
vote from Nikki Haley and Nikki Haley is
trying to distinguish herself from Chris
Christie Chris Christie is not in this
Camp of a National Abortion
ban he'll do it trust me as the
President of United States Chris
Christie would do that but he's saying
he
won't because he he truly
understands what is happening in the
country and that row rage is real and
that row rage is and will [__]
vote Chris Christie knows
that Nikki Haley knows that that's why
Nikki Haley is trying to distinguish
herself because she has started to
see her support
slip so she's got to gain support
somewhere
else she has
to
it's the only way to win this primary
which they're not going to
win they're not going to
win but that's why they're doing it but
hey but hey let me tell you something
when Nikki Haley says [__] like this
when she says [__] like this but the
debate that we're having in this country
is is there a federal law like can there
be a federal law that deals with
abortion but nobody's telling you the
truth in order I do think there's a
place for a federal law nobody's telling
you the truth I want to ban and
criminalize Women's Healthcare
Nationwide the reason why they want to
do that is because of the situation with
Kate Cox in Te Texas
folks they were not able to control Kate
Kate
Cox I don't know if you remember this
story it's a woman who got
pregnant her pregnancy became inviable
because of a condition her life is at
risk and her ability to have another
baby is at risk if she didn't receive
certain procedures to make sure that
that Health Care kept her healthy so
that she could be a mother
again but they couldn't control her it a
it ain't about the babies it ain't about
the babies it ain't about the heal
healthare it ain't about the life it
ain't about the procedure it's about the
control folks that's what fascists
want they want to control women they
want to control what they're doing with
their
bodies if they can manage to control
women they're going to start to control
other people's
bodies that's how they see it
that's how they see
it so it's very very very important that
we get this straight and right
here and the reason why Nikki Haley and
Republicans and the fascists and
Republican Nazis in general want a
federal criminalized to federally
criminalize criminalize women's
healthare and to ban their privacy
federally is because they don't want
Kake coxes to be able to go actually get
healthcare because here's the thing if
if women in Texas see that Kate Cox was
not allowed to get health care in Texas
and allowed to get health care in
another state they lose their control of
those women you see it do you do you see
it do you see it why do you think in in
in Leck Texas they banned women driving
on roads to go to certain doctor's
appointments
they did that they [__] did that
[__] they don't want to lose control of
women they want to control
them the entirety they don't want them
to vote they [__] they really don't even
want women to speak out loud they don't
want them to have the [__] First
Amendment Second Amendment they don't
want
that they don't want that they don't
they do they see women as
property that's what the control is
about that's why they're so
mad that Ken Paxton that vile [__]
fascist
nazi the Nazi general of
Texas of the fascist Republic of
Texas couldn't control Kate Cox from
leaving that's what really pisses him
off cuz that's what they truly wanted
they wanted to control
her because they want her to be a brood
May for the
state I explained to you yesterday the
Nazis had [__] camps they had sex camps
they would get teenage girls in one camp
like a summer camp and right next door
they get teenage boys in a boys camp and
they would separate them sex them up a
bit and then get them together so that
they could produce Nazis they could have
Nazi babies they were brood mares for
Hitler this is what these Nazis want in
this country that's what they were
talking about at the turning points USA
Jesus Christ you have to play that again
let's play that
again Charlie
Kirk saying when they're advocating to
marry 12-year-olds and they're forcing
12 olds to have babies and they don't
want them they want to pass a National
Abortion ban so they can ban women from
receiving Health Care in other
states I'm not making this [__] up this
[__] is
real that's what they're
doing and they're advocating for these
causes because it's not about the
[__]
babies it's not
about
life it's about these white Christian
nationalists
controlling women listen to Charlie Kirk
here to make sure I mention if you're a
young person here and you say boy you
know what do I want to do for my life
honestly you should get married as young
as possible and have as many kids as
possible hell yeah that's great that
that that fascist Charlie Kirk is
advocating to get get married as young
as possible and have babies as young as
possible in States like Missouri they're
trying to advocate for 12-year-old girls
to get
married I'm not kidding that shit's real
Mike Moon Senator Mike Moon introduced a
bill last year that would allow 12-year
old girls to get
married and they want to force 12-year
old girls not only not only to get
married but then their grown ass husband
[__] them gets them pregnant then they
can force them to car car that pregnancy
to term forced
birthers do you see what they're
doing oh Tony you're being ridiculous am
I am I being ridiculous what are you
talking about Donald Trump's on stage
saying he wants to be a dictator Grandpa
Hitler is reading [__] words from
MC the Bible of victim e minec
I don't know if you know that minec conf
is nothing but a whiny little
bitching memo that's all it is about how
we got it bad us fascist had got it but
we're the ones that are
oppressed sound
familiar it's all based in victimhood
someone else is causing the problems
that I'm causing and I
have and you can [__] ignore me you
could [__] say I'm crazy you can
[__] say I got a 10 full hat on and
I'm saying crazy [__] but folks I'm
telling you 8 months from now eight
[__] months from now Joe
Scarboro is gonna be on MSNBC on Morning
Joe saying the same [__] thing I'm
saying right now and I'm gonna point it
out to you when it
happens it's all right there before your
eyes you can see it you could [__]
smell it for crying out loud you could
smell their vile
fascism these [__] [__]
eaters it's right there in front of your
face and we can't be quiet about
it we have to push these [__]
to say this [__] out loud because it's
the godamn
truth
it's the goddamn truth speaking of
forced birthers I was on Hal show last
night I know we got a lot of sparklers
in the chat I always appreciate when
sparklers show up here at the chat I I
can I think everyone in the [__] fam
actually considers the sparklers part of
the family you know what I
mean yeah they just they just come with
a with a you know they come to the the
family get together with a cute shirt on
and it's got Sparkles over it you know
what I mean sparklers definitely part of
the [__] fam and the [__] fam you
should go be sparklers
too but last night on Hal's show he said
something that I didn't even know I
listen I study I study a lot of [__]
World War II
history I've done a lot of studying of
the mind of fascist and how they [__]
think and how their worldview works it's
[__] gross and it's
disgusting and it's much more vile than
you could ever [__] imagine they
don't even View they don't even view you
as a
human even if you're blonde hair and
blue eyes they think you're not a human
because you view differently than they
do but I didn't know this um Geral
apparently uh I believe it was Geral was
trying to um set up a science experiment
where they were trying to figure out how
to uh use science to force women to have
twins like they were doing studies on
twins
because I mean when you get when you get
a blondhair blue eyed um Nazi pregnant
by another blondhair blue-eyed Nazi you
want to make sure you're most deficient
which you know two Nazis is better than
one type [__] right I I knew about the
sex Camp thing but I had no idea about
the U the studies that they were trying
to
do to try to figure out a way to force
women to have ch
twins I mean they need an army you know
Hitler needed a [__]
Army that that's what they're
doing at this turning Point's USA
event I mean just listen to [__] Ben
Benny Ben G
Johnson the most closeted gay man in the
country I
mean I'm not saying anything no one
knows and really honestly Benny I care
less know dude to beat you really
honestly come out man maybe if you came
out of the closet you could stop this
fasy [__] and we get along but until
then let's listen to how Benji Johnson
feels about women brood mares I'm sure
he would be all for Hitler's little twin
experiment this is what it looks like to
be unshakable ladies and gentlemen let
me explain that young men we're just
going to cut right to it if you want
to be an immovable mountain in your life
if you wish to be a strong Alpha I beg
you listen
I it's at a point in my life I like the
the the bro [__] you know what I mean
the bro [__] you know what I'm talking
about where a bunch of guys sit around
and they're doing the Bro
thing and then I got old enough to
realize that toxic masculinity isn't
actually um
manly and I I came to the conclusion
that toxic masculinity is a weakness not
a
strength and really honestly the bro
[__] is just breeds it and I'm you know
our audience is very diverse meaning we
we've got about 50% women who listen 50%
men depending on what platform
really but that's that's kind of our
demographics if you want to say it that
way um dudes you know what I'm talking
about the bro [__] where your Bros get
together and you're telling jokes and
you know you're talking about squeezing
titties and you know sniffing ass that
sort of [__] you know what I mean just
the most toxic [__] you could possibly
imagine I got over that a long time ago
and every once in a while every once in
a while someone wants to Bro with me
that's what I call it oh you're you know
brosive oh [__] these
guys but the the whole
[__] the whole [__] toxic
masculinity thinking that it's manly and
tough you look like you're
overcompensating for
something
right and I don't know what Ben is
overcompensating for here I'm not sure
if the size of
something or that the closet door is
closed but keep going
man find a
woman fall in love get married have more
children than you can
afford all
right we talked about this yesterday but
this is relevant in our discussion today
as
well how r
does it [__] sound when you say find
a woman listen to this listen to it
again listen listen to it here we go
listen
again Alpha I beg
you find a woman find a woman even if
you have to [__] stuck her what what
find a woman what are you talking about
man that is the weirdest way that is the
weirdest way to to talk about how you
how you want to connect with another
human being find a woman find a woman
beat her over the head with your club
and then drag her back to your cave and
force her to marry you and then force
her to [__] you and have
babies what in the [__] are you talking
about and and staral here on on Twitch
has it right he's saying rapo yeah
that's what he's saying because that's
really how they view
women that's really how they you in
especially a guy who actually wants to
[__]
dudes and nothing against it Benny
there's dude I mean honestly man I hear
there's Senate hearing rooms that are
open and ready for your pleasure man
honestly that just don't record it okay
I'm not against Benny Johnson having sex
in the Senate hearing room with another
dude they just probably shouldn't record
it that's a really stupid idea right oh
oh yeah Tony Michaels is not against
people having sex
in Senate hearing rooms I'm not I'm I'm
not against sex I'm not going to knock
on sex especially when it's consensual
but when you're talking about [__]
finding a
woman find one I beg you you're such a
man that's what he's saying here you're
such a [__] man go find you a I'm
begging you I'm begging you whatever you
have to do even if you have to drop
something in her drink oh baby I mean if
you're at a bar and you see one that you
don't think maybe has had or has a dick
because that happens dudes listen you
got to beware they might have wieners
and that's the thing that we can't have
because then it would expose how gay we
are when we want to suck her wiener it's
really [__] weird stuff and I get
weird feelings when I think about women
having dicks so what you need to do is
you need to find one that doesn't have
one and she's really goodlooking and
Drug her at a
bar I mean that's kind of the vibe I'm
getting you know what I
mean that's the vibe I'm
getting are are you getting that Vibe
that's the vibe I'm [__] getting here
from these [__]
listen I beg you
you find a yeah rape her make make her
marry you yeah have more children than
you can afford more children than you
can
afford he's advocating for people to put
themselves into
poverty what kind of [__] message is
this go to a bar drug a woman take her
home get her pregnant make her marry you
and then force her to have baby after
baby after baby to where you can't
afford a mortgage and you got to get six
jobs
what what on Earth kind of message is
that do you see how easy this is going
to [__] be
folks do you see how [__] easy this
is going to be listen in 1930s Germany
it was a little different 1920 1930s
Germany was a little different than it
is here that's what we have going for
it's that the optimism that I have our
democracy is is much different than the
government that they had than the
Republic that they had in Germany at the
time much [__] different way [__]
different the other thing too is the
fabric of our country is way [__]
different than it was after the first
world war in Germany
way [__] different we are way less
vulnerable to ideas like this I know it
feels like oh the what but Tony there's
a lot of people believing this garbage
yeah but these people have been
believing this garbage because their
parents have been telling them this
[__] stupid [__] for [__] years
these [__] people just haven't woke
up let me show you a [__] an
interview by some of these [__]
idiots that are still believing the
[__] that their parents have [__]
told them for years they just haven't
fig figured out that their parents are
full of [__] [__] yet if I can find
it here I I got it here somewhere hang
on with me hang on there's a lot of
Clips yesterday I'm trying to get back
to some of these clips from yesterday
because I missed a bunch of them that I
want to show you and this is one of them
here this is from the Charlie Kirk
event this is the [__] weirdos that
attended this thing that haven't figured
out that their parents are full of
[__] [__] listen your age and you're
like there's hope for the future and
it's a great feeling I highly recommend
we into all the America Fest we're just
die hard Patriots we love it we love
everything Charlie K has to offer we
love turning point we just love the
event oh yeah we we love everything
Charley Kirk has to offer like telling
us to go out and Drug women at bars and
just find a woman and [__] rape her
and get her pregnant that why she has to
force to marry you and then you can
force her to have babies for the rest of
her life oh and by the way the shades
are
awesome what the [__] is this [__] man
you kidding me whoa yeah we've been to a
lot of Turning Point events together met
a lot of cool people oh yeah we've tried
we've really tried we've really tried to
do what Benny said about the women here
at turning points events because we know
all these women here all they want to do
is have
babies the [__] a lot of fun experiences
so yeah we're happy to be we just love
the environment and speakers and being
with like-minded people and getting to
hear about the amazing things that are
going on in our country and how we can
the amazing things that are going on in
our country they're they're taking away
my
rights oh they're taking away my rights
now I'm gonna I'm gonna be quite honest
with you in a couple years these women
here these young ladies
here they're going to regret they ever
talked into this microphone and said
this stupid
[__] the amazing things happening in our
country they want to marry your little
sister to grown ass men and force her to
have babies as many babies and young as
possible is that they could possibly
have [__]
dingling all
right that's what it
is this is this is what they're trying
to
do do you see it yet do you see it
yet like when I'm telling you they're
trying to sex up 12y olds and force them
to [__] have babies of grown ass in
and have 9 10 12 babies as many babies
as that [__] woman can possibly
[__] handle so that they can breed
White Christian nationalists into our
country that's what they're [__]
doing they're Nazis they don't want you
to have
individualism they are not for your
[__]
Liberty they want to force you to be a
part of their [__] religion and their
religion is white Christian
nationalism
Nazis they're [__]
Nazis it's craziness listen improve and
be better and grow both um in our
mindset and spiritually um well our
grandpa was persecuted in the Soviet
Union and so we definitely know what
it's like to have our beliefs and morals
under attack and so it's really cool to
come here and hear what's going on in
America and how we can as the Next
Generation step up and kind of like find
a solution to that so yeah
wait holy
[__] I know it's disheartening I know I
I I get it you're like godamn that sucks
man I can't believe these people these
young people these because Tony there's
a poll that says this
thing listen
folks most of the young people in this
country aren't going to be out there
going to political events especially
political events that are trying to
[__] advocate for them not to have
rights and for the men's to the men's to
oppress the women's okay most people are
not doing this this is few and far
between and my guess is most of these
stupid [__] idiots that are going to
this event their parents had made them
go to this event just like their parents
have made them to go to whatever college
that they're at where where Charlie Kirk
and his [__] Force birther fascist
show up to [__] convince people to
just start having babies drop out of
school and start having babies just do
that why do you think they hate gay
people you know that right you know that
white Christian nationalists hate
[__] gay people because gay people
can't
procreate they can only adopt and they
don't want they do not they do not want
the lgbtq community adopting babies they
want to to be raised in a white
Christian nationalist home because they
need to be good Nazis any babies are
Nazis they're good NA I mean they're
going to be Nazis okay eventually we'll
grow them up we'll raise them to believe
crazy ass [__] and to murder Jews and to
murder people who are not like them and
commit genocide and they'll be good
Nazis and we'll have a whole Army and a
whole country of white Christian
nationalist
Nazis
it's a
thing I I know Amy Says K people K
people make babies I know this it's
their thought process Amy this is their
Pro thought process yes gay people can
have babies it is it is true there is
science out there but that they're
trying to do away with the artificial
insemination of anyone but white
Christian
nationalist frankly they're going to
force they're going to force Force women
to be pregnant that's what they're
talking about it's what they did in Nazi
Germany and when a woman couldn't be
pregnant what other use does she have to
society huh what do you think happens to
those women listen I I know I I know
this sounds like all hypothetical and
[__] it is
not they're going to be saying this [__]
next
year they're telling you now who and
what they are
they're telling you who and what they
are out loud you just kind of connect
the puzzle pieces you know what I
mean see if these guys can conect
connect the puzzle pieces probably not
have being around with so many people
with similar beliefs and know that we're
not like kind of alone in like the Sea
of blue especially since we're going to
college okay you notice that that's the
a trend here with these [__] idiots
that come to this turning points USA
because that's the [__] that they
feed them right that's sheep food that
they're feeding them and and these
people are just being interviewed after
they've been fed the Sheep food that oh
liberals hate you and liberals don't
want you to be who you want to be look I
don't give a [__] what religion you have
I don't care if you're a [__] racist
I really don't I don't even give a [__]
if you're a scumbag who thinks that
women are broodmares I don't care if you
think that that's fine you are welcome
to have those stupid [__]
beliefs you don't
however get to legislate your beliefs on
everyone else you don't get to take away
our Liberty because you think that we
don't like your beliefs I don't like I
do not like white Christian nationalism
it's [__] dumb it's dumb as
[__] it's murderous it [__] leads to
to genocide folks white Christian
nationalism leads to a [__]
genocide they're
Maniacs the ones that truly believe
it like Mike Johnson truly believes that
[__] Ken Paxton believes that [__]
they're [__]
maniacs and that's where the [__]
genocide
starts but they got to get the Sheep
food out to convince these people that
genocide not that bad because the other
people walking around the country are
your [__] mortal enemy because they
don't like what you believe who gives a
[__] if people don't like what I sit
here every day and say [__] that people
don't like I don't give a [__] it is my
right it is my Liberty to say what the
[__] I want it truly is now YouTube gets
to ban me Facebook gets to ban me
eventually I might have to use my First
Amendment right on my own website but I
get to [__] believe what I want to
believe you in the chat get to believe
what you want to believe [__] I welcome
descent here I'm one of the only
[__] on the left that actually
welcomes descent one of the only
[__]
I'm one of the only [__] that
brings it up on screen when someone
descents especially when it's someone
who's on my side now I like to pick on
Shaz in The Shard Army because they're
[__] boneheads and I like to show you
how to you know beat their
ass keep going there Captain acne so
just the idea of that like we're not the
lone person around it'll just be like
good to be around like the great
conservative atmosphere and see speakers
like Rob Schneider Brandon
[Laughter]
Tatum great speakers like Rob
Schneider oh [__] oh [__] me you gotta
be kidding me right come on man
man you don't believe I mean look I get
that
you great speakers like Rob
Schneider oh
[__] oh goddamn he's like I really like
that Roseanne Bar lady she definitely
didn't seem drunk at
all come
on I mean
this is the same thing this is the same
thing yes Rob Schneider is is is an
antier which makes him Maga right he's a
qanon right again we gotta start
understanding ideology in this country
the reason why the reason why Manga uh
incorporates so many [__] types of
crazy is is because they well their
[__] form and fashion is craziness
the crazier the [__] better so
whatever the ideology is that's why
that's why maanga loved RFK Jr they
[__] loved him because he was antix
and they're like yeah he's saying crazy
stupid [__] we love it like and the
Dumber the better really honestly oh
[__] the Dumber the [__] that they're
saying the
better but yeah that's that's how it
works that's how ideology works that's
how parties work that's why that's why
when I say that Liz Cheney is trying to
save the Republican party she's trying
to save it to where uh they they
actually are are trying to get it to
where there is Maga and Republicans but
Ma Republicans are Maga MAA are you
can't unaz something that's not a
[__] thing folks you cannot will not
and and and this is why I'm so [__]
furious when I say these things about
these [__] Republicans who are
anti-trump who are trying to adopt our
Coalition for their cause to save the
Republican party it's not
savable listen to me they will not say
the Republican party you never ever ever
ever ever ever ever ever ever will get
the
stank of Nazi off of it the dude Grandpa
hit Hitler is standing in front of a
[__] microphone in front of tens of
people with a camera and a microphone
and a teleprompter and he's reading that
victimhood [__] mine
comp the victim Bible mind C my
struggle and he's blaming blood
poisoning on
immigrants I mean and it it's not just
immigrants it's [__] black people in
this country it's it's mixed race people
in this country they're going to kill
them that listen to me listen to me very
clearly these [__] [__] here
that are talking on this microphone will
gladly sit back as they [__] kill
interracial people in this
country and they'll be like well they
weren't likeminded see they didn't
really think the way I thought so you
know that's just the way it is I guess
and you know they were poisoning our
blood our blood white
blood they're gonna kill
people and these [__] idiots like
this are going to stand back and be like
well I mean you know they had it coming
they were poisoning our
blood what do you want from
me and to think that you're going to un
do that that you're gonna undo that
ideology you never ever ever ever get
the stank of Nazi off
something why do you think why do you
think I encourage Donald Trump to say
that keep saying the stupid [__] why do
you think I encourage actual Nazis to
expose
themselves the reason why is cuz we need
to know who they are we need to know and
sunlight is the best disinfected you
should not be looking away that's like
Shaz here that's like Shaz here Shaz you
can't get the Nazi off of you man you'll
never get the stank of it off of you no
matter how much you try no matter how
much you change you'll never get the
stank of Nazi off of you you will always
be a
Nazi you will always be a
Nazi always have you seen the movie in
glor glorious
bastards there's a couple great scenes
in glorious
bastards and and the character Aldo rain
uh Brad Pitt's character in that
movie they they TR they try to give you
this sense right and tell the story that
you never un naazi
something and part of the movie is that
Nazis wear uniforms right right now the
Nazi uniform in America is a red M
America great again hat or a trump 2024
shirt or Shaz in the comments saying
Trump 2024 when he was for Ronda santis
before I got
banned weird stuff weird stuff I guess
he figured out that he if he was a
dissident he he would be killed in the
genocide as
well but in the movie there's scenes
where Aldo rain Brad Pitt's character
asks the Nazi do you plan on taking that
Nazi uniform off after the Nazis lose
and their answer is yes I I don't want
to wear this uniform because I don't
want people to know that I'm a Nazi
because you can't wipe that stank off
you you take the uniform off but Aldo
rain in the movie says you can't take
the Nazi off so he would carve awasa in
their [__]
forehead so they can never take the
stank off they can never hide the
stank it's not a thing you wipe off it
just
isn't it's not a thing you wipe
off so good luck to you fellas keep
going I'm Charlie Kirk hopefully and all
all those great speakers to take care of
the problems in this country and he was
he was I mean he was everything that I
could ask for so he needs four more
years let's get him out there four more
years so he can straighten this country
out for us what brings you guys out
today uh just trying to get to a place
where people are free and people can
agree with the like-minded things warm
weather people can
agree and think like-minded
things it's the exact opposite of
Liberty they don't believe in Liberty
they don't believe in democracy they
want to force you to believe what they
believe or they will kill you I know I
know it feels like it's extreme but
folks they're going to start saying
it they're going to start saying
it mark my words there's going to be
videos of sheep waiting in line to watch
Grandpa Hitler at a Nazi rally and
someone from a traiter TV news network
is going to hold a microphone in front
of their face and they're going to say
well yeah Donald Trump maybe he is the
next Hitler maybe it's not such a bad
thing maybe it's not such a bad
thing I'm telling you it's gonna [__]
happen and they're gonna air that [__]
live and he's gonna [__] love it he's
gonna [__] love
it oh he's gonna [__] he's gonna oh it's
gonna feel so [__] good when they
finally give him permission to be their
[__]
Hitler that's what he's looking for
that's what he wants he wants permission
to kill you and kill
me and kill everyone who descents from
him that's what Nazis
do look
authoritarians and
authoritarianism is a
disease and it can be it doesn't have to
be right-wing like authoritarianism does
not have to be
right-wing
but if you look at history and you look
at right-wing authoritarianism versus
left-wing T style
authoritarianism
baby the Theocratic fascist oh man they
take the cake when it comes to genocide
and killing their own people they take
the
cake and that's what we're up
against and they're trying to brainwash
these [__] and they're doing a
good job of brainwashing these people
people awesome people amazing
environment in just an
electrifying area to be with a lot of
young conservatives I love America and
it's like super fun to be around other
people that have the same value these
people don't know what the [__] they're
talking about I love America and it's so
nice to be around people who who say the
same [__] my parents
say the same [__] that my parents have
always for me to
say what the
[__] what wa the [__]
up um
Shaz dude who are you trying to fool
what are you talking about Republicans
stand for the Constitution what are you
talking
about you know that Donald Trump the guy
that you're typing in the chat he wanted
to [__] on the Constitution did you know
that did you know that he typed out on
Tru social that he wanted to suspend the
Constitution
you're full of [__] dude you are listen
Chez do me a favor do me a favor because
you've been here for a while and he came
back right after the ban do me a
favor vote for the guy who's gonna stand
for the Constitution vote vote vote for
Joe B even if you don't like him vote
for Joe Biden because when Biden wins
he's not going to come around and try to
[__] murder you okay because all your
disantis com on Facebook they're going
to find those they're going to find them
man the Nazis are going to find
them they're going
to so just just do me a favor and you
sound every once in a while you say some
[__] about constitution rights and all
that I know you got a skewed View and
you're dog turds are [__] jealous
about how dumb you
are do me a favor so that you can
continue coming here here and trolling
me just do the right thing vote for
democracy you don't even have to tell us
that you do it that's the great part
about being Democratic and it's the
great part about like freedom and rights
and Liberty and the Constitution is you
don't have to tell people who you
actually you can lie about it you can
[__] lie it's your right to lie you
can just say yeah I voted for Trump I
voted for Biden so I wouldn't [__] be
murdered just do the right thing it be
all right be all right if you do the
right thing you don't you don't even
have to you don't even have to you don't
even have to you don't have to tell
nobody
[Laughter]
okay all right let's go back to shaz's
shart Army here Shaz is this your
brother it feels like this is your
brother talk to me about Generation Z do
you think there's a conservative
Awakening going on right now um I
definitely think so um within the past
few years um Joe Biden office hasn't
gone great and I think the young people
are
so my mom says my mom says that that Joe
Biden's really old and that and that
he's a really bad for our country and
that that that Donald Trump is is is our
savior and that he's Gonna Save Us from
from Joe Biden who who is sleepy but
he's also evil and vow he's he's a
mastermind he's a criminal mastermind
even though he can't put his shoes on
and can't
speak this is so stupid right am I
[__] am I off my rocker here this is
really
dumb these are the [__] whiny little
[__] though these are the whiny
little
[__] to the whiny little
[__] how it
works all right let's
um you're welcome to show all these
clips to your
to your family uh speaking of Liz chany
and the Constitution since Shad brought
Shaz sh Shaz brought up the
Constitution uh Liz Cheney was on Fox
News the other day yes I'm gonna pound
the Liz Cheney drum I know a lot of
people don't like when I talk about Liz
jany but it is something we need to talk
about we have to talk about this and we
canot we cannot lay this down we have to
understand exactly what is going on in
the political discourse and Liz Cheney
is trying to sa the Republican party and
they are not savable they are dead it is
a
corpse okay you again you cannot get the
Nazi
stank off of stuff you can't get the
Nazi stank off anything it won't happen
they won't un naazi the Republican party
now but go ahead let's hear how she
wants to save the Republican party and
how she frames it up as the
Constitution every single president
Republican and Democrat
since George Washington has ensured the
peaceful transition of power Donald
Trump tried to seize power so we can she
was part of it by the way she was part
of that I don't know if you know this
Liz Cheney Liz Cheney wasn't just some
[__] person in Washington she wasn't
just some Congress person she wasn't
just the only Congress person that's
voted to
Wyoming Liz Cheney was third in
leadership in the house caucus of
Republicans third right behind Kevin
McCarthy and Steve SC she was
third [__]
third to believe that she didn't know
what the [__] was going on and how they
were gonna try to steal the election is
absurd it's ridiculous and it's a
[__] lie it's a lie and she's lying
to you when she goes on these programs
and does this [__] but continue
uh disagree with Biden policy but the
fact that he tried to seize power the
fact that he ignored the rulings of 61
courts okay now remember she's on Fox
News and you just heard her say even
though I disagree with Biden policies
right and she goes down for the courts
and all that [__] and all that listen in
December of 2020 after all those Court
battles were lost Liz Cheney was still
getting out in front of microphones
saying stuff like well the president
still has legal remedies that could
happen there's certain legal remedies
well what about what about this fake
elector well this state elector well you
know there might be some remedies in the
states so we got to we gotta see we
gotta see we gotta let this Pro this
coup process play out that's what she
was
doing okay Liz Cheney wasn't fighting
for the [__] constitution in December
2020 she wasn't fighting for democracy
in 2020 or December 20120 that's a bunch
of
[__] now listen to what she says the
fact that he ignored his own uh attorney
general his own White House counsel who
told him what he was saying about the
election you were IGN you were [__]
ignoring them too you [__] [__] you
were ignoring them
too you weren't [__]
listening keep going keep digging a hole
now remember she's on [__] Fox News
here wasn't true his claims were false
and he went out and made them anyway
knowing that the extent to which he
while a violent mob was assaulting the
capital he wouldn't tell them to leave
instead he tweeted against his own vice
president and he poured fuel on the
Flames those are lines that can't be
crossed and and look this isn't about oh
those are those are lines that can't be
crossed you hear that those are lines
that can't be crossed
h i wonder I wonder why in December 2020
there were L those lines that couldn't
be crossed she wasn't speaking out I
wonder why it took 190 days it was 190
days by the way Liz Cheney was third
third in leadership in the Republican
house cauas behind Kevin McCarthy and
Steve
scalise at that time they ousted her
because she went to the floor I don't
know if you know this it took LZ 190
days she went to the floor of the house
after 190 days after the election and
she said out loud that Trump lost that
he's full of [__] he lost and they got
rid of her they got rid of her out of
leadership because she told the truth
190 days 190
days they got rid of her the Nazis
kicked her out of the Nazi
party because she wasn't a good
Nazi good enough Nazi I mean she was a
good Nazi listen and and look this isn't
about policy I voted with Donald Trump
93% of the time oh oh oh oh this isn't
about policy it is isn't oh well excuse
the [__] out of me this is what I've
been telling you this isn't about policy
this is not about policy Liz Cheney has
to be
anti-trump no matter what she is not
going to be welcome back into the Nazi
party folks Paul Ryan Mitt Romney Chris
Christie Adam kinzinger Ken Buck they
will not be welcome back into the Nazi
party why are the Liberals in this
country why is the pro-democracy country
are a pro-democracy Coalition in this
country so [__] afraid to speak out
against them when their fight is to save
their party from Trump listen to her
listen to her
listen this is about the nation it's
about the Republic it's about the
Constitution oh oh it's about the nation
okay it's about the
Republic okay it's about the
Constitution you you catch
that she didn't say it's about
democracy she didn't say that [__] she's
on Fox
News and she's giving away the game
folks I'm telling you you [__] you
[__]
you follow Liz Cheney's words at your
own [__]
Peril sh ain't for a [__]
democracy it's it's it's about the
Constitution it's about the Republic
it's about a nation she wants to save
the Republican
party she don't give a [__] about
democracy and just because we are
willing in the Pro democracy coalition
to tell her to [__] off you do not get
to be part of our [__] [__] Coalition
not only that you definitely do not get
to use our coalition to save the
Republican party because that's what
she's really trying to do the Republican
party is dead and the only way that it
survives if we let
it if we let
it if we let her save the Republican
party we are responsible it is us and
folks I'm telling you you can't get the
Nazi off of it and you won't be able to
unaz the Republican party now it just
won't happen it's not going to happen it
it it it is bad
politics it is bad for our
nation it's horrible for our
nation if we allow the Republican party
to do what they've done to us with
Donald Trump and MAA again because they
will they will do it again they did it
once they'll do it again
especially if we save
them if we save the Republican party and
we want Paul Ryan and Liz Cheney back in
charge of it they'll do it
again you can't un naazi that [__] you
just can't you can't trust me on this
doubt me if you want
to doubt me hard really
honestly oh boy because do I have a
doozy for you that you can't undo some
of this stuff this one I'm telling you
now when I watched this at first
I I I didn't think this was AI but I
didn't think this was real right I I
really thought that this was
satire this is one of the craziest ones
I've ever
seen one of the CRA craziest ones I've
ever seen and I know I show you a lot of
these [__] eater
videos that that you know puke up all
kinds of garbage into a microphone but
this one's
wild holy
[__] this this guy is gonna be [__]
raising his
hand I wantan I want Trump to be a
dictator that's what he's gonna be
doing very
soon listen to this [__] it's crazy what
ways did he make your life specifically
better while he was President Trump made
this country great again I truly believe
Trump made this country great again and
the foundations that this country stood
for Trump made this country great again
oh really well some [__] you've now
convinced
me if he made it so great where the [__]
did it go
man I mean listen greatness isn't isn't
wiped away by by someone who is dementia
ridden in in a matter of three years
okay that's that that's not how
greatness
works if he really made this country
great the dementia ridden Grant paaul
Biden wouldn't be able to wipe away that
greatness okay it just that's how you
know that's how it
works go ahead but exp I'm asking for
specific right about what Trump did made
the country great again Trump wrote me a
nice check what can I say Trump wrote me
a nice
[Laughter]
check [__] I really like that
socialism that's his
answer like like [__] Trump's on
stage like look they're poisoning our
blood all these communist socialist
Marxist and then his his [__] sheep
are outside like yeah we love
socialism what okay we'll keep going I
don't know maybe you're on to
something during the pandemic during the
pandemic well I would say you're a
bigger one I'm sorry to cut you off I
would say during the planemic the
planemic oh yeah yeah gotta get that one
in that's a good Facebook meme right
there it's not a pandemic it's a
planemic okay well let's hear the racism
here cuz I'm sure it's coming when so
what is tell me about that explain
planic well I mean we all know Co you
know this whole thing was orchestrated
Chinese trying to veto Trump out of
office I'm Chinese the Chinese trying to
veto Trump at office this guy doesn't
even know what a [__] veto
is he definitely knows he likes that
socialism Trump chick all right but wait
till you get to the the good part oh
this is a great part about this check
just focus in on the socialism check
here let's let's stay focused here
[__] Jethro I'm looking at
you and you know we're not
stupid we're not look here look them
Chinese Ved Co to try to veto
Trump and we're not stupid or something
okay all right all right well we'll
prove it
so be that as it may and I I don't I'm
not a scientist I don't know that part
but but you know Biden wrote a bigger
check than Trump um to to support you
during the
pandemic so oh you like socialism do you
let's talk about
socialism let's talk about whose
socialism dick is bigger than
who I love I love dick measuring
contest I love it I love dick measuring
contest dick measuring contests are
always great right it always it always
really shows who the who who is not
manly at
all these dick measuring contests it's
it's the same thing when you're driving
down the road and you got some guy with
the big [__] tires on his truck it's
all jacked up he's got four Trump Flags
well you don't see him a lot anymore
because there's not a lot of these
idiots supporting this this idiot
anymore but you don't see him like but
you every once in a while every once a
while you see one of these [__] these
these these these spread necks these
[__]
trumpers out in the wild you know what I
mean and they've got this this truck
that's got a quad cab with an eight foot
bed you know it's a it's a it's a
two-ton truck and they've never haul a
goddamn thing in the back of it besides
a couple Trump Flags like that's the
[__] biggest payload they've ever
hauled this guy it's this guy but that's
a dick measuring contest you know that
kind of contest but listen to this dick
measuring oh my God this is great his
administration did what is it about
Trump's check that was
[Laughter]
sweeter I love how he asked the question
oh my God what makes that Trump cash
sweeter than that branding cash Jeth
brow what is
it ah tell us what is it I hear has
personal autograph on there I tell you
what
he had
his he had his personal autograph on
there what the [__] he signed it he
signed that check Donald J trip oh boy I
tell you what [__] me do you see why I
thought this was [__] not real I
honestly thought that this guy's like a
Larry the Cable Guy type thing you know
what I mean I'm dead serious man what
the [__] is going on it gets better I
know you like Tony this can't get better
oh it gets better watch I tell you what
D did it for
me what wish Trump could be my
[Laughter]
dad I wish Trump could be my dad he says
oh my
god oh and big step's like yeah is it a
fake I no it's this is [__]
real this is [__]
real this is this is 100% it ain't AI
this guy ain't goofing it's [__] real
you're like Tony it can't get better oh
yeah oh yeah he loves Trump's signature
he wants him to be his daddy but
listen oh you go on nicer trips probably
hell
yeah
you'd go on nicer trips if he was your
daddy this guy's like I'd love to suck
him off goddamn he could be my sugar
daddy yeah [__] yeah I love them Trump
checks when he puts his signature on
them what in the actual [__] is
happening what in the actual [__] is
happening Royal says I've been saying
they want they want a daddy yeah this is
all that really U um this is that white
male
incel homosexual feelings repressed type
thing where they they they need a daddy
you know what I mean they need a daddy
they need I need Boy sign him chicks he
put his signature on them checks let me
tell you what I wish Trump was my daddy
I wish he he'd take me into the Senate
hearing room and give me what for really
spank my ass you know what I'm saying
you know you know what I'm saying I tell
you what boy I tell you what I heard
from stormmy Daniels that he could
really hump good for like 35 seconds oh
buddy oh man that's what I want I want a
sugar daddy like that what in the
[__] oh my god oh
boy you gotta love
it you gotta love it and I I I I know
most of you like Tony you shouldn't be
you know joking about this this is crazy
this guy's
nuts this guy vote this guy does not
vote okay all right this don't be afraid
of this guy this guy does not
vote he no he does not vote that that is
the actual other thing about the Trump
[__] support is most of these [__]
idiots like this these white men like
this in this demographic go look it up
go [__] look it up and it's easy to
find the data like of demographics of
people who vote you can actually find
that data it's actually reliable data
I'm not going to show it to you I'm not
going to shove it down your throat
though you can take my word for it
though the demographic in this country
that votes the least they vote the
least is white
men white
men white men white
men oh my God someone says it's an actor
I I mean I really want it to be satire I
really do cuz it's so [__] funny it's
so [__]
funny but even if it is satire even if
it is
satire you still believe it's them
right
yep Big Sean say isn't it young white
men though yes but white men in general
go go look at the demographic of white
men cuz white men listen white men don't
have to vote folks white men don't have
to vote because white men are in control
of everything so why do white I mean all
those white wrinkly ball sacks they're
going to do what's best for me so why do
I need to even care and vote that's why
they don't vote because the power
structure in this country is white
men it's the thinking trust me I is one
this is the [__] attitude
this is the attitude that they have this
is the thinking this is how they're
[__]
bred it's the whole reason why like Mike
Johnson's like yeah I've got an app that
makes sure I know what porn my son
watches and he knows what porn I
watch
right Mike Johnson can't just trust his
son he's an
Overlord right and his son's like well
as long as I have this Overlord
I'm good to go because my Overlord is
going to make sure that no one [__]
with me they'll [__] with women they'll
[__] with they'll [__] with the lgbtq
community they'll [__] with brown people
they'll [__] with black people long
before they [__] with me I'm good I'm
safe there's nothing I need to do
because I own Society
anyways it's the
mentality
it's the mentality I'm telling you I is
one I'm a white
man this is how it
works now I mean you know the thing is
is every once and again a white man ends
up with enough brain cells to rub
together to try to try to figure out
that hey this is all a bunch of [__]
[__]
so let's see I'm going to see if Gab
Sanchez I think he's got a show today
we're going to double check here while
we're on here so give me just give me
just a second show today question
mark see if he's got that going yet I'm
GNA need that link link if so link if so
link if so gave Sanchez all right uh
let's move on uh to another clip here
while we're waiting to see how G
speaking speaking of white men and white
Christian nationalists now
I really had to look this up yesterday
um Rob
Smith I didn't know who this was not
gonna lie Rob Smith apparently he's got
a show I went and watched a few clips of
it it's really [__] horrible now Rob
Smith I think I think he's an openly gay
man I'm pretty sure he's an openly gay
man now he went to the um um to the
event in Phoenix okay and I think it's
the turning points USA event that he
went to come on I'm going to go to his
um he's look he's Army veteran anti-woke
real talk yeah okay um and here's the
description he's a decorated Iraq war
veteran he went to Colombia so he's an
elitist and he can't you can't count
cancel Rob Smith podcast now now Rob is
again I think he's an openly gay man
okay um if he's not um
they think he's
gay and I I could show you a clip of him
maybe you would too but that's not the
point here that's not the point um in
Phoenix he went he went to the turning
points USA event
in so he went to hang out with a bunch
of white Christian nationalists okay he
went to hang out with them um and he he
made a video of these white Christian
nationalists calling him the n-word and
the fword you can see him right here on
the screen he typed him out okay in this
video they're they're doing that now
this is the people he's trying to court
right he's on the right wing this guy is
not a leftwing commentator anti woke
that says it all he's trying to tell you
I don't I don't like I don't like them
the gay stuff okay uh on his Twitter
feed he talks a lot about the milit
because he's an army veteran uh and
wokeism in the military he's a Tommy
tuer right he's a Tommy tuille Tu tuille
the football and and the government see
see see the government like the football
but the football not like the government
and and and and we we want we want to
make sure that the
military doesn't get promotions because
of the football see how the football
Works he's a Tommy tuberville tuber
Viller
okay now he goes to this event in
Phoenix which is a white Christian
nationalist event and as a black gay
conservative okay and he's surprised
that they shouted the n-word with a hard
R and the fword with a hard T at
him he's really upset about
it really upset now I'm gon to show you
this video and if you got sensitive ears
I don't know why the hell you're here
first off but if you got sensitive ears
you might want to turn it off but here
you go here's a video of them yelling
and screaming at him at it appears to be
a restaurant listen to this I got here I
[Music]
got look at that I got some I
got wait a
minute yes Nick Wood says loves gay
sex
I mean maybe Rob knows hell I don't know
he says Nick Fuentes love gay loves gay
sex apparently Rob thinks the same thing
about Nick that I think I think he's you
know a little lightting the loafers but
you know whatever whatever you want to
do Nick whatever you want to do Rob I'm
I'm not against it you know be you be
you that's cool I just don't want you
[__] telling other people so here is
a here's Rob after he says that Nick
quentes loves gay sex listen to what
happens after
this no he
doesn't [__] [__] [__]
[Applause]
[__] there you
go there's
Rob in Phoenix Arizona
had a white Christian nationalist
convention
surprised that they hate him hey Shaz
hey Shaz if you're still here listening
hey Shaz this is your fate eventually
this is your
fate this is your
fate it's what they do he's black he's
gay he's a republican he's
anti-woke it's not enough
it's not enough for these America First
Nazis and of course they're Nick Fuentes
fans that's he knows that that's why
he's saying
that it's it's how it's gonna happen
folks I don't know Rob I don't I don't
[__] know Rob I don't know Rob I have
no idea I have no idea who he is I
didn't I didn't know about him until I
saw this video
yesterday no
clue
it is the fate of these people Gabe
Sanchez says he will not have a
broadcast today and he's going to be
changing his broadcast schedule so
that's what he says that's I'm just
relaying the message I'm trying I'm
trying to make sure that you get the
correct time so I I'm guessing that he's
going to be doing a show today but at a
different
time so uh we won't have Gabe Sanchez
after this you have to go somewhere else
I mean I know you wish I could do three
hours one of these
days one of these days maybe I'll do two
hours I will or three hours excuse me
three hours every single day we'll get
there I appreciate all your support I
appreciate you guys continuing to show
up on YouTube Facebook twitch and now
Instagram and I appreciate all your
support make sure you um you follow me
on patreon go to the tony.com let me
show you how to get there go to the
tony.com you can follow me on patreon
okay now I would love your support on
patreon and if you want to buy a
membership a lot of people have been
doing it by the year you get 10% off
your patreon membership when you when
you pay by the year and a lot of it's
getting really popular patreon just
started this where you could do that
recently but they also started where you
can follow me for free on patreon so
make sure to go follow me over there but
if you want to show support do that as
well make sure to join the book club the
book club is getting hot they were there
yesterday they were doing prequel the
audio book from Rachel mat they're
having a discussion actually popped in
on them right before how's show but it's
sponsored by the library of democracy
make sure you go f fi follow the library
democracy's YouTube channel as well as
there's going to be more and more
project 2025 videos coming out but if
you want to join the book club just
click the link on the Tony michaels.com
the reading win every argument by Min
Assan uh so so you can you can go do
that and also I want to thank everyone
who has linked their Amazon Prime
account to their Twitch account it's
helped out the show a lot U through the
ban we had to go on Twitch so a lot of
people were becoming aware of twitch but
if you have your Amazon Prime account
linked to your Twitch account do not
forget to renew it every single month uh
it is very important that's the only way
that I actually get the subscription
credit from Prime from Amazon and I want
to thank everyone for following me over
there while we are on our band and we
really increased the size of the um the
twitch channel so thank you very much
and I
also I also want to thank you for
joining the Facebook group and following
me on Facebook and now you can follow me
on Instagram and watch on Instagram all
those links are on the Tony
michaels.com again appreciate all your
support same time same place tomorrow
remember we're going to be all Thursday
and Friday this week Monday Tuesday next
week tomorrow will be our last show
until next week
Wednesday same time same [__] place
Serv that
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's mebor head ass
speaking
you've compared yourself to Rosa Park
saying if she didn't sit in the back of
the bus you shouldn't have to either
meaning you didn't want to sit in the
back of Congress how else are you like
our beloved civil rights leaders Rosa
Parks believe it or not is one of my
favorite political figures why wouldn't
I believe that oh I had a portrait of
her in my office can I list civil rights
icons and you tell me what they mean to
you Marsha P
Johnson very respectful honorable person
keep going respectful and honorable
about what on all all the stances and
all the work Mara P Johnson yeah what
does that mean just keep going next you
don't know her yeah I do keep going do
you I do go just keep
going James Baldwin huh James Baldwin
who the hell is James
Baldwin who's James Baldwin Harvey Milk
I have no clue who that is okay okay
move on you're bossing me yes yes
Queen you're the only Congressman to be
expelled without a conviction is it safe
to say you didn't come to the capital to
make friends I wasn't there to play nice
I was there to expose the rot and
Corruption and I did and I'm going to
continue to do it Republicans and
Democrats alike swampy slimy people
selling this country down a river who
else in Congress is committing fraud
they're all frauds name if you if you
were to if you were to put me name if
you were to put them all under the same
scrutiny I was put under you'd [__]
vacate the whole goddamn building can I
name them and you just wink if I go
ahead marjerie Taylor green no Kevin
McCarthy yes Lindsay Graham yes Matt
Gates no Bob Menendez Absol gold bar
Menendez Dan Goldman he doesn't pay his
rent Dan good Dan Dan is owing
$180,000 worth of rent right now on his
$45,000 monthly rent which is what most
Americans make a year you let that [__]
sink in you were seen walking around the
capital with a baby in your arms yes
look at this baby speak Congressman
Santos what are you doing to stop the
ongoing genocide of pales do not record
this baby we using the baby as a prop no
I was taking the baby to introduce him
to another member of Congress when you
do decide to have a child would you
rather have a gay son thought daughter
or pathological liar I will have a child
and I will accept my kid in any way
shape or form come and the best I can do
is teach my child to be better than
me